Hachi Machi middle class famous tour
update can't be uh-oh we got a couple
alerts going out straighten them out a
little bit Kansas City Springfield St
Louis Nashville in the Philadelphia that
show sold out already three months ahead
of time we added a second Show tickets
are on sale right now then we're going
up to Providence Rhode Island that's
going to sell out in Boston there's low
ticket alert so get those tickets now
we'd love to see you do it welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage a little show we sit
there with your favorite comedians and
we find out they're good to be classy
after just a big old piece of trash I'm
your host stage Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antodi's basement she's upstairs just
picked up a new metal detector okay yeah
start it in your room if I can comb in
the walls looking for the money okay all
right that missed my co-host is coming
up well I mean the metal detector
doesn't find money to come
what are you talking about I thought I'd
get a laugh I don't know okay my co-host
is coming at you so it did work he is
the CEO of are you garbage he's an
international businessman he has not to
be trifled with in the Board Room or the
bedroom yep or the bathroom Okay putz
give it up for Kippy Kevin James Ryan
Hey gang thanks for tuning in as always
make sure your rate review subscribe
over there on iTunes full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are
cooking and then obviously the greatest
guy goddamn website of all time
www.patreon.com sign up you get a bunch
of [ __ ] bonus content bunch of videos
get the cribs episodes we went golfing
we did the Dave and Busters with our
guests today we did a bunch of [ __ ] we
went Camp the whole nine yards check it
the [ __ ] out yeah gang having a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us oh
look good he crosses the t's he dots the
eyes he works the ones the twos and the
threes give it up for T-Bone McMuffin
Toby McMullen everybody what's up dudes
what up t-ben you know what kind of guy
I am what's that I'm the kind of guy who
appreciates a guy who shows up late with
two tall beers
dang the long hair ain't lying what the
hell happened today
start the day it's three o'clock Jesus
Christ the car
gang you [ __ ] know him you love him
he's back for his fourth or fifth time
he is the papa shot Champion
2022 yeah how could you forget
the day of my life
it was [ __ ] up how close that was to
my wedding because it that was the best
day of my life so
probably got more money out of it though
okay give it up for time to car
everybody hey thanks for having me boys
I'm sorry I'm late I'm sorry I'm drunk
sorry I'm dumb and drunk
no I'm trying to get my tolerance back
up it's gonna train it for the Olympics
got Tokyo coming up in a few months
I'm up to two Sixers a day now why are
you trying to get your Tower well why
was your tolerance off I took two weeks
off drinking before the wedding and it
plummeted and then I was the first night
I drank I was like I'm [ __ ] hammered
was that for like vanity purpose you
wanted to tighten it up I was trying to
tighten it up yeah and I had been on a
bender
I'm in the middle of five wedding
weekends I'm just getting hammered all
the time and just my normal day-to-day
life
um
I needed to take a little break try to
hold off to cirrhosis for a couple of
weeks I don't want to look yellow in the
wedding pictures
[Music]
how was the wedding oh it was it was
insane it was so good but it was it was
the best day I got to play Wiffle ball
the day of oh my God
I do live the life of a 12 year old it's
true yeah sounds like a lot like Dennis
the Menace well before we started
filming you said he had plenty of pizzas
there that is true there was I had a
taco truck and pizzas it was a taco
truck there yeah yeah that's a [ __ ]
solid move yeah I mean there was no
dinner so that was the food
but it was a hit it was a good it was a
Buria truck [ __ ] incredible
um you just go up and order whatever you
want yeah yeah nice it was sick
um yeah it was it was it was the best
day played Wiffle ball went and got
married uh wait who did you play Wiffle
ball with I had some Rascals out there
yeah all the regular Riff Raff a couple
of Street tops regulation feel where
were you playing at we were playing in
McCarran Park I love it it's it's uh
it's my greatest athletic all my uh
athleticism is [ __ ] like Papa shot and
Wiffle ball and darts which by the way
we had so we did the family reunion at
Dave and bought the totally family
reunion at Dave and Busters full vid on
uh over there on patreon did open bar we
had the food he texted me like a half
hour before the thing started he's like
dude I'm here practicing where are you
at you're like what though I got there I
was early for that late for this
shot in here the sternos weren't even
late when you got there we don't even
have we didn't have access to the room
like I had to see the manager I was
getting my own beers before I didn't
need the opening oh we got the invoice
don't worry
hey is that idiot in the back with you
I'm like yeah I like how after like an
hour or two would be in there when you
found out what could be paid for you're
like [ __ ] I should have had my wife I
know it wasn't that expensive not
expensive and he's like dude this is
crazy this is so this is awesome because
this is the best day of my life is what
he told me it was it was my dream it was
so [ __ ] fun it wasn't even that
honestly for like whatever there was
like 30 of us we all got cards we all
got unlimited booze for three hours it
was food uh and it really wasn't that
expensive and I told you what I made for
a cream I should add my wedding
genuinely upset it is yeah I [ __ ] up
how did you make out on the wedding uh
almost we're almost wait what's that
Cash Wise oh we're almost back to even
okay it was an expensive wedding and uh
some people gave us a lot which I was
like [ __ ] I invited too many people for
the supreme pizzas
and we spent all our money on dodgeball
that's right two toppings and we're not
getting no thin crust
[Laughter]
how many people are at the wedding it
was uh including the taco truck guys 70
172. that's a big wedding that's a big
one it was it was big it was very
stressful and also it's like comedians
of the [ __ ] worst people on the
planet and they're all my I got a spot
at nine yeah so many Comics were like
sneakily dipping out coming back and a
lot of people probably asked yeah but
what time do you go on yeah yeah get out
of here I legitimately got you like that
people canceling like a day out because
they got a looney bin feature spot
like it's crazy and they don't tell you
that like I found out through like a
friend yeah they're like I'm gonna be at
uh Uncle Chucky's [ __ ] house uh this
weekend and I'm like I thought you
rsvp'd yes to the wedding they're like
oh yeah I thought you didn't care and
I'm like a bunch of [ __ ] money piece
of [ __ ] you're the best man dirt ball
what are you doing
yeah Comics are notoriously bad with
yeah for sure anybody dress out of sorts
oh yeah yeah uh what was the attire it
was supposed to be like cocktail attire
yeah you show up ready to play with a
football classic
you wear your Pinstripes
we're doing home jerseys this is my boys
stickball Chic where you find his cleats
and uh yeah no I would have uh there was
some people dressed to play Wiffle ball
like it was all my friends all of her
all of her friends and family dressed
incredibly and then I had a buddy show
up in a long sleeve t-shirt and he was
like it's long sleeve though you know
that's the fancy one the best is the
justification for it yeah yeah that's
[ __ ] he was like it was one of my uh
hotter guy friends and he was like look
I'm a hot guy and nobody cares how I
impressed that he was kind of right was
it in a church did you get married it
was at the Bell house and really yeah
okay so you did the whole thing there
and you yeah we didn't we got married at
a little Italian restaurant the night
before because we didn't I didn't want
people to watch us do that okay so it
was just a party so it's just a party no
we had speeches and they it kind of
turned into a show it was great it was
we had to get our spots in
I had to do I had to bail her anything
go to the stand up New York somebody in
the audience who books this you know uh
what was where was the Italian wedding
where'd you do that that was in
Williamsburg at a little season yeah
yeah finest Olive Garden we did check
out an Olive Garden like place and I was
like this would work for me this would
be good I know there's some about
there's all those places are great yeah
and who married good my mom your mom did
yep yep she claims that she's certified
for
we'll see she didn't show me her
credentials but but that's all the
paperwork so we'll see that's really all
formality right you're married at in the
in the court no you still need I mean
you can do it that way we did it she
swore that she was an officiant so we'll
see don't you have to have paperwork or
something we had to get the paperwork on
your license yeah we had to get the
license like application no but doesn't
your mom have to have paperwork saying
that she's alive I didn't look at it but
she said she had it she does not have it
she claims she's ordained we'll see how
did she do she great she killed yeah she
killed it although it was like again the
next week yeah yeah she's uh she's
featured you host of The Bell House
no it was uh it was great it was just
hammered yeah gradually we had a nice
little hotel for it and I uh staying in
a hotel in the city you live in is a fun
time it's cool vacation that's cool I
was like I'm such a penny pension [ __ ]
that I was like we don't have to get a
hotel but the place was sick and the end
of the night she wanted to go home
earlier than I did and I could you can't
leave you can't let your wife go home
early and then you on the night of your
wedding so I was like [ __ ] let's go back
and I woke up she was sleeping with a
half empty box of pizza I'm in the
middle of my closer I did have I snuck
two burritos out and uh and a shot of
Fireball I had like a little nip of
Fireball and I because she she went to
bed earlier than me and either we had a
little balcony and I smoked a cigar and
zipped a little nip of Fireball by
myself and she woke up and saw the scene
out there it was like what the [ __ ] did
you do on our wedding night who did I
marry yeah yeah
that's good stuff funny congratulations
thank you boys that's great let's get
into some cues here gang Tom so glad to
have you here gang when you know when
you sign up for the patreon get your
questions right on the air we got Mr Tom
takar Papa shot Champ here with us to
answer your question your garbage
questions here uh all right this one's
from Nick uh first time long time ten
dollar homie is it garbage to name your
kid after a band A co-worker named her
kid Steven Tyler
that's yeah that's a bad look yeah but
it could be worse at least that's like a
go for something yeah or like uh I don't
know uh Guns and Roses Guns and Roses
Jenkins
you know my daughter Neil Diamond
laughs I don't think I grew up with
anybody with wonky names either though
we were kind of like very generic uh uh
80s 90s names yeah it got it got goofy I
would say kids that were born in the
2000s in the 2000s yeah I know people I
think the goofiest one and this is a
Midwest and southern thing I think but
Nevaeh oh it's backwards Heaven it's
like a religious thing yeah yeah it's
anything backwards yeah yeah yeah yeah
yep backwards head it's old it's all bad
yeah a lot of Tyler's a lot of Tyler's
my cousin Jordan a lot of Jordans a lot
of dylans yeah I remember in the 2000s
ours I've like a lot of double like uh
my my nephew's name is Stevie James
there's like uh Sarah Jones Stevie James
is all right it's kind of a cool name
actually yeah I like it that's not bad
Stevie James is okay that is yeah
old country name sure that kind of got
like but that like open it up for jelly
roll
that guy's killing
uh Southern uh uh musician right he's
not like a maybe not a rap I don't know
how to class I don't want to box him in
uh I would say Southern artist voice of
a generation there you go exactly well
put
um but yeah I think he's a Nashville guy
or something he's killing it out there
um jelly roll jelly roll also the name
of the band my sister had played our at
her wedding was jelly roll they're all
local is that true really oh they're a
Philadelphia people but I've never heard
of them I know Mr Green jeans or G love
in the Special Sauce well G loving the
specials everywhere
Mr Green jeans was a cover band at a bar
in Manayunk what are you talking about
he was the finest musician I ever saw
that man put on a show oh [ __ ] I missed
the green jeans they'd get you laid I'm
not shaking I missed your green jeans
I'm just saying everybody's [ __ ] into
Mr cream cheese those are gonna be
creamed green jeans they start playing
Jumper by Third Eye Blind that gets all
the girls
there's a hot song about suicide where
you tell somebody not to kill themselves
and maybe after she jumps off that ledge
she'll come [ __ ] me it's a slow one
that's my point wait you're slow dancing
to jumper
that's that's gimpy's what he's always a
[ __ ] uh a brick
Oh my God yeah yeah
they were so I remember like people get
their weddings around that like they
lock the band in and they play Originals
or covers it's like a 13-piece band a
rich who the ones Originals at the
[ __ ] oh give me give me some [ __ ]
you know Four Seasons or something play
the new stuff for our first dance
this is off our new album
play the electric slide you idiot
give me some loving or get the [ __ ] out
that was a problem at our wedding is uh
my lady my wife like really wanted to
like reggaeton music and nobody I mean
people were dancing but then uh The
Killers Mr Brightside came on and people
lost their [ __ ] minds and she was
like God damn it yeah she was really
[ __ ] losers yeah yep what's reggaeton
like reggae no it's like rappy like I
can't explain I don't know how to
explain I'm a dumbass what's dubstep by
the way everybody's talking about
that's old 10 years I just heard it the
other day what is it what's this Hip Hop
[Laughter]
what is everybody's talking about
that's not my kind of rock and roll I
just heard where have you been hanging
out dude that's crazy
I swear to God I just heard people
talking about
on Twitter or something like that in
your time machine
what is it what is it it's like is it a
dance move
man yeah that the Harlem Shake Harlem
Shake was all right was that the
pandemic the Harlem Shake what no no
um stop asking questions because you're
confusing me more just getting worse and
worse I think I'm confusing with the ice
bucket challenge
no dubstep is a form of like I would
qualify Tech like Rage music okay
but it was a certain kind of whatever
certain had a certain kind of Rhythm to
it or like characteristics that made it
dubstep but it was like a subset of you
know
uh all the DJs yeah the big DJ I'm Going
Insane Clown Posse for my life that's
what I'm naming my kid
Uncle Cracker the car
whatever happened to Uncle Kracker I
feel like I just looked he's probably
got to be around I think I just saw him
on Tick Tock or something yeah he's he's
definitely I feel like he's definitely
like probably a millionaire somewhere in
his life but he only had he was a true
one-hit wonder right he just had nobody
worked with Kid Rock
he did all those lives he was you know
yeah what was this song it was featuring
I got a feeling no uh no step back from
that ledge my friend this was that final
me and everything oh yeah
although there was a rumor in my school
that it was about heroin so we weren't
allowed to listen to it anymore even
though I don't even think that's true uh
yeah I don't think that was sure
everything was about heroin yeah it's
music
Chase talk about chasing the dragon uh
well if you want to see Mr cracker you
can scoot on out to Wild Hogs Saloon and
Eatery there you go [ __ ] Walford Indiana
Oh on September 11th I love it November
11. never forget maybe that is
disrespectful you should not perform in
a damn bar that's gonna be a celebration
of America right I love I know what town
is when a town is in Indiana and I've
never heard of it I'm like that is a
[ __ ] up that's a bad town that was a
[ __ ] up time we should go to that show
I mean that'll be [ __ ] that's hey a
lot of red white and blue you gotta make
another patreon tier so we gotta get too
quick yeah yeah we gotta hit it in a
week
I'm going anyway
that's pretty good okay let's talk about
DraftKings baby you mean the king of the
draft Yeah the NFL is upon us my friends
and as you know DraftKings sports buck
is the official betting partner of the
NFL and they're trying to get people to
sign up yeah you know what they're doing
what's that an offer you can't refuse my
friend oh boy five dollars
get you 200 in bets instantly and free
look at that instantly Daddy-o that's
what we're doing and as an added bonus
for week one everyone can experience the
thrill of draft DraftKings early with
early win promotion that's ass money
right there listen to this you bet on
any of any NFL team to win if your team
leads by 10 at any point during the game
you get paid instantly even if your team
loses guys this is what it's all about
you download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app now and use promo code
ayg to get 200 in free bets instantly
when you place a five dollar bet this
Sunday five dollars get you 200 and free
bets instantly that's code ayj support
them they support the show only at
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the NFL minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply C
show notes for details do it yeah Kip
you say Helix Helix Helix we're talking
about the greatest mattress company of
all time we're talking about Helix here
yep I pooped in one today
how do you like to sleep man do you
sleep hot do you sleep cold do you sleep
fat like me me all you got to do is go
over to the website take the quiz two
three minutes match you with the perfect
matches for you bozo over here sleeps
bald
he got the Twilight mattress he liked it
so much they went out and they bought a
king yeah money back into the company me
and a bird sleeping on a Twilight
Twilight mattress baby best sleep of my
life if you're a bozo out there sleeping
on a mattress at your dead grandmother
but you know died in dude something or
whatever get out of here go get a
grown-up mattress what are you doing
here uh they offer a hundred a night he
doesn't sound like Grandma was murdered
hey I didn't see nothing all right 100
night risk free trial try out new Helix
mattress see if your body adjusts and if
you decide it's not the best fit you're
welcome to return it for a full refund
everybody's unique as the big man he
sleeps like a lard ass that's him that's
not me what is it 90 days they give you
a hundred nights a hundred a hundred
you think they're doing 90 nights
they're doing 100 nights a C note of
knights Helix what are you doing trying
to make some money I know right they're
giving a store away
um it's fantastic Helix uh mattresses
are American made and come from come
with a 10 to 15 year warranty depending
on a Model there you go all the way down
here's the turkey Helix is offering up
to 200 off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com garbage with Helix better
sleep starts now he'll sleep.com
uh all right let's see here
um this is from Kevin P
um growing up in Coal region
Pennsylvania my parents referred to the
night before trash night as garbage Eve
so they could go trash picking trash
picking oh God I was dude we have a
trash pick as a kid I always wanted to
find like a bike or something oh I see
you know I wasn't like digging through I
was picturing like you're like looking
at banana peels and stuff no it's not
like I'm looking for a retainer or
something I was looking for like [ __ ]
coffee grounds are still good I'm
getting there two three cups out of this
wash them off they're fine we would we
wouldn't do that but uh it was it was a
common theme around our area that if you
wanted to get rid of something you just
put it out in the front lawn yes yeah
everybody everybody understood what the
deal was if you put it in the driveway
it was uh it was it was a rush yeah got
to get it out of there before you have
to go to work in the morning yeah that I
still I still feel that way if I don't
want something I just put it on the
sidewalk and of course oh yeah in New
York it's weird yeah you walk you'll
walk by an apartment building there'll
be like three sets of shoes a couple of
Records yeah people take it six year old
crabs yeah yeah [ __ ] diceye
I've grabbed [ __ ] off the street I've
never done that a painting like just you
know
like something like that like something
like that sure a lot of times I have
seen that yeah so we found out find out
fully stole the Mona Lisa he's the guy
steal the Mona Lisa find out I'm really
Banksy
would know what dubstep is yes
um we have it in the building where
people put stuff down there's like a
shell for like a windowsill people put
stuff in the building like you know
[ __ ] a radio or [ __ ] whatever
they're trying to get rid of before they
throw it out but it sits there for like
a
maybe a day and then the guys in the
building [ __ ] toss it it's always
weird when you see people like throwing
stuff like when they got like a new
cabinet or a new dresser and they put
the old one out there sometimes it's
like how the [ __ ] long have you oh man
it looks so old and so bad so broke did
you ever [ __ ] hit that with pledge or
something yeah I mean Jesus you just
would have spruced it up a little bit
yeah I'm guilty of that I know I don't
want to dust what are you talking about
you let it build up enough until you
throw it the [ __ ] out do you have uh
proper cabinets in your bedroom uh no
like where do you put your where's
yourself I have a weird uh they're in
little shoe boxes wait I swear to God
yeah I don't love the system we got
going what do you need a little shoe
boxes we have shoe boxes like regular
shoes yeah regular shoe boxes and we put
uh like cardboard shoe boxes and we put
away the my underwear and socks are
folded into them okay we have three
pairs of socks and two pairs of
underwear I mean how many do you need
awesome
also we just went over your sock
inventory your sock system I got a
drawer though okay and plenty of them I
mean how many I buy socks every couple
years and they a couple of years yeah
yeah how often do you need to buy
something at least I got three months
left I gotta re-up soon I'm squatting in
these socks
shoe boxes yeah shoebox everything else
in the closet uh we don't have we only
have one closet in the whole apartment
it's not very big so I have like a weird
we found this metal scaffolding thing
okay out on the street and we brought it
in the house and I just set all my
clothes I know exactly it's like a
little dress it would be like a workshop
type thing yeah yeah that's all right my
shirts and stuff are stacked on that and
most of it to be totally honest most of
my [ __ ] is in the laundry bag and I pull
it out as I need to use it sure it's
within the laundry bag we do the wash
and fold and then I just slowly pick at
it there you go all right that's at
least a gentleman yeah yeah
I respect that the bag and then the
ripped open plastic inside yep yeah not
a good look but it's safe it's way
better than [ __ ] putting it you know
especially when you don't have a lot of
clothes yeah you're like what I'm gonna
put these two shirts over here just
leave it there this will be solved in
three days
I hang all my T's all my teeth hang all
your teeth that's why too much respect
for these teas yeah oh everything's
hanging I mean I don't hang them but
they're they're hung
who hangs them the lady the neighbor
yeah yeah my lady ain't doing that [ __ ]
she doesn't like to she doesn't like to
deal with the laundry I get it I don't
like to eat I [ __ ] hate it I hate it
it's like my job but I I go get it like
washed and folded I'll do it myself and
I'm like that's I've done my part uh and
now we're just picking it out of the bag
now will you go if you have to do it
yourself do you have a place in the
building or do you go to like the
laundry I gotta walk to a laundromat
yeah it's nice it's my exercise for the
day I knew you wouldn't go back always
I'm always working it's not a bad
company does this benefit me you know
it's not a bad couple hours because I
tell you what once you get it in there
you only got 25 minutes so you got to
flip it then you got like an hour and a
half to chill
I don't do that I leave I just drop it
for the wash and fold now okay although
when I was doing we do have laundry in
the building but one time there was a
actual piece of [ __ ] in the laundry it's
my biggest fear dude yeah yeah oh I hate
it yeah and it was mine but look
it's either here nor there no I yeah
there was there was [ __ ] in the in the
lot in the washing machine and so and it
doesn't you think the washing machine
it's like it's a washing machine wash
the [ __ ] out I know it would just gotta
go somewhere oh it's a solid turd right
there someone's cranking out the fiber
yeah damn you know how people say that
if you own a gun you're more likely to
get shot do you think the way that you
live your life is results in [ __ ]
winding up in your washing machine that
could be it's like one of those things
you dance with inevitable yeah
this is on uh FanDuel of that happening
in my life
yeah when you keep your underwear in an
air max box you're really rolling the
dice yeah it's like if I step in [ __ ]
yeah there's a good chance [ __ ] is going
to be on my clothes
in there too I'm fighting a vampire into
your house
I mean you're crazy yeah uh yeah uh this
is from Herman
um
is it garbage to not watch a football
jersey you wore when your team want us
to not watch the magic off so
Superstition I I see where he's going
but I would say never [ __ ] wash a
football jersey what are you you're
getting it that dirty that's true I feel
like you're playing yeah oh yeah I guess
if you're playing no I don't I don't
think Herman's playing I know I took
that as you're watching the game I
thought that too I didn't even see he
was playing maybe he's playing how old
is he though I mean we don't have like
high school kids listening This Guy's in
his 30s yeah at least my cousin listens
shout out to the CB South Titans yeah
but he's your cousin very true probably
pay him to listen
yeah keep the demographic
find out what Dubsteps are
gonna get some ad dollars out of this
I've got to tap into the younger Market
here though these kids are spending
their mom's money let's go
uh buy a 2 000 shopping bags these kids
are whales I didn't have I don't think
I've ever do you own any football how
many do you own any jerseys I have if so
what shoe box are they in I want pizza
boxes I used to be any type of box I
keep around that's true
you just gotta wash it off a little bit
save those IHOP containers yeah you keep
the little ottoman thing in there and it
keeps it safe
um
no I uh I used to be a big Jersey guy I
could I could picture you when I was
like basketball basketball jerseys
mostly but I did have I had some Colts
jerseys I had a Peyton Manning and a
Marvin Harrison and Joseph had died did
you spring for the really expensive ones
who just went for like the it was always
the cheapest one one time I got [ __ ]
on that because I went to TJ Maxx and
that's which is my Play I'm trying to
get a sponsorship number 19 on the most
yeah
that's a basketball jersey
it's like the Peyton Manning but it's a
jersey but it's actually a t-shirt
who are you fooling with that you know
it was sweet back in the day do you
remember the t-shirts that had like the
stripes right here they were it was like
it was almost like elastic yeah it would
have a number on it those were pretty
funny that was they were like kind of
baseball jerseys yeah right yeah that's
more fish yeah yeah yeah yeah but I went
to um I went to TJ Maxx and I found a
jersey that was uh it was uh T-Mac it
was Tracy McGrady and I was all hyped it
was on sale it was like 20 bucks and it
was like a Nike jersey it's the only
nice Jersey I ever bought and then I
real I found out he got traded that day
yeah
it's a throwback I'm retro you're like
one of those kids in Africa like a
Buffalo Bills Championship shirts
running around oh man I love that they
do that by the way I thought that was
when I learned that as a kid I thought
it was the coolest thing that's one of
those things that's like so funny that
it feels like it's not true I would want
one of them just for like you know
um we talked about this before I think
what is the classiest Jersey
in Europe this used to be a question
yeah if you hadn't you were going to a
wedding and you were like [ __ ] the only
thing you had was one yeah Jersey of
each major sport oh what would you wear
or any sport you could only wear that I
think uh I think a baseball jersey is
the classic Yankees Pinstripes I think
it's just the button it's a button up
button up that's not bad I think that's
what Chris said on that you're in
business honestly nicer than uh how Sean
Donnelly dressed for my wedding
I think the the most socially acceptable
in the summer would be a basketball
jersey no way at a wedding at a wedding
at a wedding man not at a wedding just
in general public I think you can get
away with that I think football is
definitely football and like hockey are
the worst
no well feidelberg from Barstool and
this is a good I think it was him he
said I would go uh hockey jersey because
it is technically called a sweater sure
and that is a that is an article strings
always so baggy I think they are yeah
the football football jersey I feel like
is usually a bad look that's the worst
yeah it's not good you just see somebody
in a [ __ ] uh like rain dams Jersey or
Raiders people wear them to weddings at
a funeral or something same yeah the
last wedding I went to somebody was
wearing in Indiana somebody was wearing
a football jersey and it's like really
small yeah did you have a conversation
with him because I would love that's
that's Dirtbag as my family is that's
never he's put on a collared shirt like
the type of people who have the balls to
do that aren't the type of people you
want to talk to at the wedding I mean I
would just want to know like what was
your thought process yeah did your house
just burn down what happened is it on
fire did you just run from uh Sam
Townsend it's the most expensive thing
they own so they go oh this is right
that's true this is the best piece of
clothing it was 150 dollars 150 shirt so
it would be you know what I mean how
much did this run
is a true classic I generally I
generally just don't find them
comfortable now obviously I don't have
the right the good body for it what
they're made for you what are you doing
yeah those tackle that is like not no
commentary on your body here but like
it's the football jersey is the male
MooMoo like it's what it's what it's
like our pregnancy clothes you know
I can go with it also make you look a
little Jack too because they got the you
know they make you look more jacket well
I put the pads on
wearing a helmet at the wedding at 142.
that one that I have hanging doesn't
have the uh the the elastic on it that
was my high school Jersey so we we we
all took shoelaces and put her put it in
through the little like the little area
in here and tighten them of course we
didn't realize that you needed that
flexibility so we were all [ __ ]
running around getting [ __ ] laid out
across that dude yeah
we couldn't lift my arms up the other
team must have been so hyped to look at
you and be like oh these guys are
[ __ ] guys don't even do high fives
you're doing chest bumps and stuff it's
like an old Star Wars figure if you low
hit me low
oh man
you are a bozo all right this one's from
Joe new 10 homie has anyone in your
family ever bought and installed
spinning rims from Walmart my divorce
dad picked me up from school one day and
a 10 year old Eagle Talon with plastic
Spinners and LED lights in the
floorboards that's when I knew I was
absolute trash
that's tough I knew one kid that had him
in high school and he genuinely thought
they were cool like didn't do it as a
joke they really hit hard when people
when those plastic rims came out a lot
of people got on top of those I wanted
them I thought they looked cool as hell
yeah I gotta be I wanted the spinning
one I thought but I always had a piece
of [ __ ] car I mean although that's
usually what they were on yeah oh yeah
for sure the actual ones are the metal
one Spinners were pretty sweet yeah it's
free Wells yeah yeah shout out to
Latrell spreadwell he invented those
that was that true
I thought of it right when he was
choking that coach I got an idea
you know it would really improve the
aftermarket value of my car
choking the [ __ ] out of you uh yeah it
was his uh he had a rim company or a
customization company and they were
called the spreewell the sprees
genius yeah those are cool as hell yeah
the Lamborghini door forget it oh yeah
that [ __ ] land because people started
putting the doors and flies up on like
Jeeps yeah
but Lamborghini does on the Escalade son
man shout out to pit my ride huh yeah
yeah the exhibit x to the Z baby I would
love to see a doc on like what those
cars look like now the Pimp My Ride cars
well they were all comedians I came to
find out friend was on it oh I was just
talking to somebody I thought it was I
guess I thought of it you look at a Toby
like he produced I thought it was his
buddy or something there was somebody no
no Tiffany haddish was on uh yeah it was
like a casting call I mean yeah and also
they hit them MTV does that a lot yeah
you think it's a contestant and all
those old mtvs I watched them a lot me
and my me and my lady love to like watch
like the date my mom and like parental
control and [ __ ] because it's so awesome
yeah and scripted next is like one of
the funniest [ __ ] shows of all time
if you watch it now because I thought it
was real when I was a kid and then you
watch it now and you're like I was a
dumbass like it's so clearly scripted
you think cheaters was real because I
got the feeling I think cheaters yeah I
think cheaters was real that was fake
that was fake God damn it why don't I
don't believe in anything anymore
no [ __ ] I mean the WB come on let's go
uh who is the boss the second who even
is the boss no but they used to give
them you had to pay the tax bill because
you can't put fifty thousand dollars
into a car
like they they that's gotta be yeah they
had to pay tax that's like a gift yeah
so they had to pay the taxes that's uh
somebody's like hey you can't afford a
new car but yeah
immediately wait I don't understand why
because
yeah like when you go if you win the
Price Is Right you have to pay the taxes
on the showcase showdown yes what yeah
you didn't know that yeah it's a huge
that's like you can't just give away
things like that yeah some people turn
down they're winning yeah I don't
[ __ ] want it because they're like hey
to leave here you gotta give us you
gotta write a check for 11 Grand if
you're in the [ __ ] studio audience
you don't have it here you know what I
mean you're not licked two o'clock on a
Wednesday yeah you're a couple tall boys
you know it's people like to call her I
the second you said that I was like I
gotta go to that price is right one of
these days
I gotta get that that's crazy what they
said how do they expect people to
[ __ ]
oh man that's a [ __ ] rip-off I didn't
know that uh-huh yeah you gotta pay the
taxes on it I mean no [ __ ] yeah was
the best yeah I guess you could probably
because you could win Cold Hard Cash
with Plinko right so you got to pay tax
on that too yeah but I'd be like oh give
me half yeah if I won 10 grand but give
me five right yeah take your Italian
vacation and stick it up your ass I
remember he's a new Watcher and dryer
that bad the vacations pissed me off I
was always like that's like three days
you can't like some people are winning
like cars that's what I want and now I'm
like I love the vacation four hours at
Niagara Falls
Barker's with you making the move on
your girl you know he's making a move on
your lady and she likes it oh yeah and
you kind of like it too he did well Bob
did well okay let's talk about that
bespoke post baby uh also known as the
box of awesome they do offer the box of
awesome there and they like to break it
up in the season sometimes right now we
still got a little bit of the summer
there's still time for Adventures
there's still time to get out there do
some hiking do some outdoors we're
getting ready for the fall or get ready
for the fight ready for a bonfire some
nice grooming items some cool outdoor
cookware some bar things you stir it
like that Shaker Martini's cool they got
cool guy stuff cool guys [ __ ] you got
box awesome here they're cool you're a
bozo over here you could be over here
but you got to get the box awesome to
come over here so what do you want to do
Bozo awesome Bozo awesome go awesome get
a box of awesome and enjoy yourself the
big guy ain't lying folks I tell you
what they sent us about a thousand
things so far we each got knives we got
a hammock we got uh they just sent me to
the smoker for the cool cocktails I'm
doing everything over there I'm like Tom
Cruise and cocktail on my place my
knife's next to my bed uh-huh yeah cut
your fingernails away guys to get
started just take the quiz at
boxofallston.com your answer is going to
help them pick out the right box for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
each box is valued around 70 dollars but
you pay a fraction of that fraction at a
price plus with box of awesome you're
supporting small business nearly 90 of
everything that comes from box of
Awesomeness from a small up and coming
brand and a call to action the turkey
jerky you get 20 off your first monthly
box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com enter the code garbage at
the checkout that's box of awesome.com
code garbage for 20 off your first box
box of awesome.com go garbage I'll do it
if you could be on any game show which
one do you think you have the best shot
at taking the cash down
oh that's a I feel like somehow I feel
like Deal or No Deal I would never
understood that I hate that show it's
the worst show it's that's like
that's what the briefcase is right the
briefcase it's fully random there's no
skill but the idea I don't know how it
lasted as a show you're just watching
people open [ __ ] suitcases and then
you're like yeah I guess that's how much
money I got I don't know they did that
on 30 Rock with gold yes and they had
they had the three girls standing there
and yeah they all had briefcases the one
on the end was like barely holding it up
number three that's a great one actually
I think Wheel of Fortune I think I would
do well with it Wheel of Fortune was all
right yeah I love Wheel of Fortune the
wheel of that hour of TV is so funny
because Wheel of Fortune is for the
dumbasses and Jeopardy is for this like
smart people oh yeah so I'd watch that I
finally didn't even watch Japanese yeah
it was a waste of time go clean your
glasses door dude I sucked it I sucked
at Jeopardy oh dude no one in my family
was ever it never even got turned on I
would there be whole bracket it's where
I wouldn't understand that what does a p
have to do with anything it's a dude it
took me easy it took me the longest time
to understand answering in a quest yeah
give them the question I was like what
is this I was so confused I do like it
now but because I like trivia [ __ ] but
it's I think I would do very poorly no
there's a hole like I'll tell you what a
bunch of sections I couldn't do me and
my girl play it on her phone which I
think we do pretty well at that [ __ ]
Family Feud let's go that's that's yeah
you two screaming at each other as a
family feud just to hang out with Harvey
for a couple hours yeah all right any
type of domestic violence that they
could throw into there public screaming
Family Feud
what is it was her fault it should be
that would be interesting where are the
keys
what'd you do with my [ __ ] ties
why would she have your ties those are
my shoe boxes
you put your [ __ ] in your shoebox
she have her stuff in shoe boxes too
it's all shoe boxes all right let's drop
the [ __ ] Chewbacca it's like a
goddamn Foot Locker over there it's not
what it looks like in the back I think I
got a nine of that there's a bunch of
shoe boxes and suitcases under her bed
with our clothes it's a pain in the ass
to get anything shoot it [ __ ] sucks
Catch Me If You Can over here look I
come here to escape my life I didn't
come here to be ridiculed I didn't come
to your place of work with booze to be
ridiculed
[Laughter]
largest self I didn't even know I didn't
even know they made them that day dude I
mean I know there's the regular then
there's one step but that's like a Mondo
guy well trying to get that talented
that's the only way to do it no they
only sold this type in this size of can
oh that's not a good sign
oh no by the way quick aside I just got
uh 10 bucks from the lime Arena
Corporation because of a class action
lawsuit I feel like that might be the
most
that's like the trashiest thing I think
I mean that was one of the big questions
we've only have you ever been involved
in a class action also no one's ever
said yes so we stopped to ask him I just
did some two people sent this to me and
I was like wait actually I could get in
on this schedule would you get
mesothelioma or something hey still
addicted I can't I can't give up the
stuff I Got Scurvy I thought they told
me there was limes in there
I think it's okay
we could all go down
it's bigger than I thought just so
everybody knows after lawyer fees it's
only 6.50 look this thing goes all the
way to the top
oh sleepy Joe has his hand in this it's
truly gay 2022.
on this whole thing go to my apartment
they're just strings and little Bud
Light cans all over the wall where does
this go
um no so what happened and what's funny
is I actually shouldn't have been
because I knew that this [ __ ] like that
there's not tequila in a Bud uh Bud
Light Lime Arena I knew that because
they couldn't sell it at bodegas or
whatever yeah so it's a multiple yeah
yeah so but they got sued because people
were like no we thought there was
tequila in here real so I get 10 bucks
because it was just like if you had
drank they just said list how many of
them you drank between like
2017.00
yeah hold on sorry I I know how to speak
idiot yes uh so there's like a website
if you have ever done this yes please
sign up you go to that website and check
it mm-hmm well I know I don't check it
somebody sent it to me yeah it's not
like a clad like because they knew that
you partaked and yes that was my big
thing for a while yeah lime aritas
hahaha I was like how trashy is it to
drink lime aritas than to sign up for
the class
then to wait around for this it was it
was that worm wasn't real
having to list how many and what type I
drank was a low point in my life I think
so did they ask for any documentation
there's two there's two sides then I do
have a picture to me I do have on my
Instagram there's just a sad picture of
a Lime-A-Rita can from back before I
realized Instagram was like gonna be our
whole career I thought it was just like
yeah you post dumb [ __ ] pictures on
here and I had one of just me drinking a
lot there's just a can of a lime Rita
that I just finished it was a very sad
picture but that's [ __ ] I did have
documentation but there's two four parts
of the uh Forum one is if you have
documentation you could make like 20
bucks but without they were just like
yeah just say hurricane honestly you
guys get no it's just total if you guys
want that 10 bucks you can get it you
can get 10 bucks right now just say it
guys you're listening out there I really
did have a bunch of lime Arenas do you
know how many people were involved in
the suit probably tens of thousands it
didn't say it didn't say on the thing
but I think this is uh I think most of
uh Indiana I was affected by this
lawsuit holy [ __ ] yeah what did you get
something about Aaron Brockovich God
damn they're gonna Vimbo me oh my God no
they're not I might have gotten fish
you only had to send them five hundred
dollars
it's a lawyer fee but you get it back
once you win let me ask you this if
right now they reached at me and said
hey how about a couple lime Maria's
instead would you get 100 yes my address
is I gotta go golf after this I would
love if I just stopped by Bodega and
pick them up can you call that you think
you're gonna get them in an hour
I need them now though
you guys got an office in Midtown or
something I want to send Priority air
to the Chip and Putt Flushing Queens
tell them they're for me oh man that is
trash
I believe I just remembered that yeah
that's the biggest score of your life
how'd you forget that that's like
finding a Bitcoin dude I see in the
shower when it came through banging on
the wall
dude it's like you were built in a lab
to be a guest on the show oh it's crazy
yeah that was one of those I was like oh
when you texted me I was like have I
done anything tragic I feel like I've
really cleaned my life up and then and
then I remember we'll take care of that
you just keep doing you making love to a
burrito on your wedding night
holy [ __ ] oh man all right he's all
right babe
How Could You Forget You were involved
in a class that's so funny I also got
food poisoning twice this week that's
the other thing it doesn't matter I ate
the day after our wedding we went from
the hotel back to our apartment
and I re I remembered I had old lamb and
rice in the fridge oh my God
I learned my I learned the hard way
because I heated up and we were going to
another hotel for our like mini
honeymoon and uh I he I was like let me
eat this so it doesn't go fully bad
right before we left and then I was ill
for the whole the whole day how old was
it
it was a bodega one it was the deli next
to me and what shoe box was this in
I put this in the Air Force One okay
these were good
holy [ __ ] and then I ate at a place
called crab Bros that uh made me the
sickest I've ever broken the dice it was
so bad who heals I had the spaghetti
who heals from eating from getting food
poisoning from eating five day old lamb
and then the next day rolls a dice in a
place called crab bro I was desperate I
needed something to eat nothing I needed
crab and I needed it from a bro
it only cost me two high fives
I just picture them sick the next day a
bro would never do this you
said a little food poisoning a little
food poisoning is sometimes all right
this really the crab Bros the crab Bros
one was bad where is this crab Bros it's
right uh it's by I mentioned the bar
that I like on this uh on the show
before because somebody reached out to
me but uh it's next to this bar called
Turtles all the way down which is the
it's my favorite bar okay it's got they
raised their prices a little bit and Joe
Biden's uh America I don't know I'm
obviously kidding I don't know I like
couch the government's fault here but
you're a dirt bag they raise beers from
a nickel to seven six goddamn Democrats
[ __ ] um no but it's six dollar beer and
shot but it's next door it's like in New
York it's really great seven seven and
Eight's even good I'll take a seven yeah
I don't mind that at all but five it was
five now at six great deal had a good
time there but I hadn't eaten all day
you know crab Bros is right there so
it's in bedside it's uh you know I don't
want to speak ill of them but it's the
worst place I've ever been
a [ __ ] class actions trying to get
ceased into six from [ __ ] the Bros
look oh that was not red dude I'll drop
it all if you give me one more free
shrimp oh boy listen if you want to come
after us you can talk to to Carl handle
all the the cars on retainer at the
moment to handle all of our all of our
crustacean lawsuits you don't have to
testify in this then
[Laughter]
I specialize in crush station law
oh my God he's like oh he's got he's got
class on University now what where was I
University of Long John Silvers
that is right up my alley brother the
guy who took down the Gordon's fisherman
[Laughter]
I was dancing you didn't have to testify
or anything right
although actually yeah I had to check a
box that was like you swear that
everything's true yeah I guess I'm drunk
what do you want yeah whatever popped up
on Mall liquor
I'm [ __ ] dying over here
the [ __ ] people sue for that's [ __ ]
crazy
um all right this one's from Thomas ever
wait outside a bar for it to open
that's bad I I'm so yes I have I've done
it for tailgate purposes of like I'd
been drinking and then like the bar
opens at two right so it's like but it's
more of an event I'm not like
waiting around for it though yeah it's
like I'm boozing sure this place starts
selling booze it too I'm gonna be
Meandering around the front of the front
of the shop I done it like a buddy my
buddy's bar like my home bar in Indiana
I would be like oh they're open at five
I'm already in the neighborhood I'll
hang out and my buddy would be the one
opening it so it didn't feel as bad as
like you're waiting for them to turn the
sign over Friday you barge in kill two
locals Stampede my anxiety doesn't let
me I never want to be the first person
in a restaurant or the last person in a
restaurant yeah if I know they're if
it's 10 30 we walk into 10 I can't do it
man because as a server I used to be
like you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I feel I
I definitely do that at restaurants 100
with you I'm out I don't like to I
because I've done that before and felt
like the biggest piece of [ __ ] when I
was in my earlier but I usually make you
feel like yeah and you should like yeah
it's a dumb ass thing to do it's not
it's not good but bars I always tell
them I'm all I'm often the last person
at the bar and I I tell them like just
tell me when you're ready to go sure and
I'll and I'll go home with you
go back to your place
back there they're still serving you
sure we told you to leave many hours ago
uh no but I always and I always tip a
lot if I'm there late sure I always tip
a lot anyway at bars because I'm like I
I want to I like we drink free so often
in our business of course
like the last two nights I've uh closed
down the comedy seller bar and I'm like
I will throw you money and the second
you want me out of here please tell me I
will be out of your hair in a heartbeat
it's a good that's always a good spot to
drink the fat black bar it's my favorite
it's the best bar it's I mean it's also
free for us sure it's different but it's
also a sobering moment when like
you're in you're in party mode and
you're like oh yeah there's like a
handful of let's say there's like 15
people at the bar and then there's ten
yeah and then there's eight yeah and
then there's five and then it's like you
and one other guy the lights are on and
you're like oh the chairs are off you
know the cleaning stuff yes that's such
a you're like I gotta get the [ __ ] out
of here yeah
The Vibes are no longer hot the other
guy is telling you about crypto and
you're like I don't need I just want to
drink I don't want to talk to you but
then sometimes the bartender locks the
door in the ashtrays yeah oh that's I'm
saying
I'm saying once even the last part of
the vibe yeah you're like it's over I
should have left 20 minutes ago being
the guys that make the cut off for the
after hours yeah I feel like you're at
the Met Gala yeah dude
now you guys are cool you guys are cool
come on man you gotta and then kick the
other people out yeah
a couple extra trips to the bathroom
we're having a good time
yeah yeah cause you got a [ __ ] so hard
Bros
[Laughter]
I got a bad poor boy I'll be back in a
minute why do they open these at every
next every bar I go to all right
constantly following me no it's but be
yeah when you're in the in like that
when the bartenders are like get in here
it's the best feeling in the world yeah
I always said in in New York City to
feel good you need a bodega like a
corner store yeah
and a bartender yep and a local Watering
Hole that'll let you hang bada bing bada
Boogie a couple of free beers that's the
best yep yep there's some Panic finding
that in New York was the best because I
had it in Chicago uh the G-Man Tavern
which is uh a great bar that I used to
go to shout out to it right by Wrigley
Field yeah I used to run a show there
and they would always hook us up with a
bunch of free beers I think the lady who
did that got fired for it but it tends
to happen when the owner's like what
what have you been doing yeah yeah
and I really want to get hammered hey
have a sip it can be quite honest with
you I want to find a dark bar oh I've
been being pretty good though so I don't
I don't want to paint it like I've been
I'm drinking right now yeah I've been
pretty good I've overall been pretty
good you're not on the stand anymore you
don't gotta lie
your honor I've been living on that lime
arita website for Ever since I clicked
the button yeah that died
love the self-awareness damn man my
[ __ ] coughing it's killing me um I
apologize to everybody uh this one's
from Keith haven't had one red is it
garbage filled the above ground pool
halfway one month then the other half
the next month to spread out the water
bill
I respect it though if you're jammed up
you got to spread it out my mom
complains about that water bill
everything he fills the pool yeah you do
have a huge Olympics which how much can
it be 200 bucks 100 bucks I don't know
T-Bone see how much it is to fill an
above ground pool I mean I don't even
know what size here right do we pay for
water for water right I don't pay for
water no landlords pay for water in New
York yeah yeah and they're charging for
that [ __ ]
it's magic you think it'd be a little
bit better quality yeah that's crazy I
mean it's a utility 15 000 gallon pool
we're only about 135 bucks come on what
are we doing here you got a family
though I guess yeah what are you gonna
do yeah it's 70 bucks 70 bucks you got
to get at it early though you got to put
that first coat on in April he can't be
opening up the pool in June or July yeah
if you're spreading it out over two
months he can't be like you know opening
a labor day and be like that's [ __ ]
party yeah shut her down yeah do you
have a pool growing up at all my uh
stepdad's mom who watched us uh had a an
above ground pool yeah and it was always
a point of contention because uh we were
too I I was scared of it there was
always spiders in it and stuff I don't
know I've always been a bad swimmer too
but we would go hang out in it it was
all right but it was it was like under a
bunch of trees in the woods and so there
would always be bugs and [ __ ] in there
same pool you were baptized in that's
real country [ __ ] right there baptized
in above ground oh that didn't fully
take I don't think
he's got bugs in his mouth really you
need at least three daddy long leggers
on you with a Chrysler let you in
um all right let's do one more and then
we gotta wrapper up here this one is
from Dr Max pounder uh are you garbage
if you know the produce code for bananas
is 40 11 because that's what you type in
the self scan when you buy avocados
I got caught I wasn't you did I wasn't
trying to do it on purpose we were
getting I was getting shallots and it
said put the code in and there was no
shallot so I just put in scallions and
all like the same thing that's good
there was a [ __ ] I don't even know
the difference there was a team of
broads on me they were like whoa what's
going on what's going on I don't know
how the [ __ ] she saw me it was like a
goddamn Casino they got an eye in the
sky okay no no you got to put this they
see they see you come in they're like
this guy's gonna take us for all we got
it's crazy I'm stealing vegetables I
would have never guessed candy bar
Skittles something they brought a cooler
to follow you around yeah they saw they
saw you buying scale they saw you buying
vegetables like something's up here so
you gotta keep an extra high on this guy
sir that Toblerone bar is not a scallion
great bar
all right we gotta wrap her up buddy
such a good time man thank you so much
we love you congratulations on the
wedding congratulations on the lawsuit
have you picked out any uh uh you know
uh investment property or anything like
that
how my court settlement ruined my life
I'm putting it right back into the
Anheuser-Busch Corporation
all right nice place for my shoe boxes
by the beach and congratulations pop a
shot Champs
2022. what do you got coming up on it I
got a bunch of stuff I I have a new
podcast by the way uh for the football
season coming out thank you my buddies
Tim McLaughlin and Connor Delante just
started a podcast called the three
Horsemen it's a cold podcast where we
shoot the [ __ ] talk football have a good
time I also have stand by your band The
Music pod Gotta Have you boys on of
course uh I'm gonna be at Kansas City
comedy club I'm going to Austin Cap City
I'm going to Louisville playing of the
tapes I'm going to Winnipeg I'm going to
Poughkeepsie uh Houston I'm all over the
goddamn place it's doing shows out there
oh I'm doing my album at the end of the
year too and special at uh Fort Collins
uh the comedy fort in uh yeah Fort
Collins Colorado come out time to carve
one of the absolute best comedians
working we [ __ ] love you kipi what do
you got for him guys we're all over the
road uh Providence and Boston are sold
out at the moment we've had it we're
working on adding shows Philadelphia we
added a second show uh working on New
York we have uh we're all over the road
check out the [ __ ] sketch guys come
see us we [ __ ] love you and we'll see
you next week peace